Look at this glass!
What do you see inside it?
Many of you would probably say
that it’s empty!
However it’s not.
Then what’s inside it?
There is AIR inside this
glass!
Yes, air is present everywhere around us.
But tell me, is air heavy?
We
generally feel that air is light in weight.
How true is this?
Let us do an experiment
to see how heavy the air is!
Take a bottle filled with water.
Now take a piece of cardboard and place it
on the
open end of the bottle!
Hold the cardboard with your hand and invert
the bottle
upside down!
Now take off your hand from the cardboard.
What did you see?
The
cardboard sticks to the surface.
This is because the air’s pressure is pushing
the
piece of cardboard in the upward direction!
Does this mean that air is heavier
than the water?
Well, the air is present everywhere, and hence
it is exerting
pressure from ALL THE DIRECTIONS.
Clearly the air pressure is more than the
pressure of the water inside the bottle.
And this allows the piece of the cardboard
to stay on the surface of the bottle!
With this activity we can understand that
AIR EXERTS PRESSURE.
You may note
that air pressure acts in ALL DIRECTIONS!
Do you know why?
It’s because air is a
fluid.
The molecules of air are very loosely held
and hence they can easily move
in all the directions.
We all know that the earth is surrounded by
an ENVELOPE OF AIR.
Do you know
what is it called?
It is called as ATMOSPHERE.
And this atmosphere is divided into
different layers as shown in this image.
What can we say about the air in the atmosphere?
The air in the atmosphere exerts pressure
on the earth or we can say on the
earth’s objects.
What’s this pressure called?
The pressure exerted by air is called
as AIR PRESSURE or ATMOSPHERIC PRESSURE.
Now the question is whether air pressure is
uniform throughout these layers of
atmosphere…
Think about it.
Where would the maximum quantity of air be?
There is maximum air above the troposphere.
There’s this much air above the
troposphere.
Then this much air above the stratosphere.
And this much above the
Mesosphere and so on.
So as we move upwards, the quantum of air
decreases.
Now logically, can you tell me which layer
carries the maximum air pressure?
Yes
the bottom most layer carries the weight of
the air present in all the layers above
it.
And that’s the reason why the air pressure
is maximum at this layer…
And what can you say about the air pressure
at the layers above this point?
The
air pressure decreases as we move higher.
Does air move?
If yes, what’s it called?
Moving air is called WIND.
Have you ever noticed the SPEED of the wind?
What
happens to the AIR PRESSURE when the speed
of the wind is INCREASED?
We will
find out the answers to this question in our
next lesson.